well I reviewed the first one so I might
as well review this second one sharknado
2 the second one it's actually called
that now you may be thinking Chris why
are you reviewing this movie there are
so many other movies out there you could
talk about well I made the stupid stupid
choice of posting a status on my
facebook that said if this gets over a
thousand likes I'll review sharknado 2
and it got over a thousand likes a lot
sooner than I thought it would so here I
am
the first sharknado film got famous
because of Twitter it got famous because
of the title of the movie I mean people
are like what
sharknado I had to see what that's all
about exactly what it sounds like it's a
tornado filled with sharks and it's
going around and people are getting
eaten alive on land where there's oxygen
because the Sharks breathe oxygen what
do you do with a sequel you go to New
York of course the main two stars in the
last film return this time and this one
is filled with cameos I'm talking filled
the pilot from airplane he's in this
movie as well and guess what he plays he
plays a pilot on an airplane Kelly Ripa
Al Roker Billy Ray Cyrus now look I said
this in my previous review for the first
sharknado they're not trying to make a
classic here they're not trying to make
an oscar-worthy film and I'm aware of
that and I'm fine with watching a movie
that's trying to be so bad and be funny
and that's cool and this movie does have
a lot of parts like that it's cool to
see a guy with a chainsaw
cut a shark in half in slow motion even
though it looks like it's a graphic from
a gamecube game that being said the
problem with this movie is that it
really tries to shoehorn in all of this
actual drama like we give a we
don't care we just want to see sharks
flying around don't try to have all
these actual dramatic scenes with Mark
McGrath from Sugar Ray yeah just have
sharks flying around and the movie has
that and it's entertaining ly awful when
that happens but for the most part the
movie is actually filled with a lot of
needless drama that just kind of ruins
the entire fun of the thing
who cares about Tara Reed she's in a
hospital oh no who cares
sure some sharks that's all we want now
poor judd hirsch shows up as a taxi cab
driver you may remember him from
Independence Day guess who else shows up
from Independence Day vivica a fox this
is an Independence Day reunion the movie
throws in quite a bit of needless flex
with baseball now look I know I'm
critiquing sharknado 2 and in a way
that's like an oxymoron or something
saying that critiquing sharknado 2 what
am I doing with my life but honestly
there really is like an absurd amount of
plot points involving this baseball game
where all these characters just start
talking about their past and you're like
just show some sharks please just
falling out of the sky that's all I'm
here for if you guys ever went in a
subway in the past few weeks you may
have noticed that inside that subway
there's all these little advertisements
for sharknado 2 you know why that is
this movie is filled with subway product
placements and I'm not talking about
just like a restaurant in the background
or somebody eating a sub because that's
in there they got Jerrod in this movie I
mean this is literally a subway
commercial at times it's crazy trust me
I actually feel like eating subway now
so it kind of worked it's cool to see
vivica a fox slicing through a shark
with a sword it's cool to see guys
taking baseball bats to sharks and just
batting them into the sky you know it's
it's dumb but it's entertaining in that
way and that's what they're going for
they wanted to be silly they wanted to
be over-the-top but the fact is they try
to shoehorn in so much actual family and
relationship drama that makes it
terrible and they don't allow the comedy
ever to get into that stuff they don't
ever allow the humor to be infused
within that drama they're attempting to
create so it just comes off as this
incredibly annoying sideline that
just kind of lengthens the run time for
that reason sharknado 2 is really hard
to watch at times if this movie was just
nothing but sharks falling out of the
sky I would've had a good time but
unfortunately there's all this actual
drama they're trying to create which was
a terrible idea
if you saw the first sharknado you know
exactly what you're getting into you
this is nothing
it's sharks in the sky
why am i reviewing this movie sharknado
2 I'm gonna give you a d-minus okay I
give the first one an F this one was
just a tad more entertaining than the
first one
it actually embraced the silliness more
however there's all this drama stuff
why so guys if you haven't noticed the
lighting is a little bit different I am
doing some tests I'm doing some
experiments I got a new camera it's a
Canon t5i I'm testing it out and doing
some tests with some lights you guys let
me know if you think it's a little too
bright or what I'll obviously be doing
some tweaking in the next few days let
me know we think below and as always
guys thank you so much for watching
thanks for watching this one and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my nice
[Music]